what was warm buffett holding at the end
of the year well i'll tell you a few
things he wasn't holding which is very
interesting he dumped his entire
ExxonMobil steak also his conocophillips
take that was sort of a minor steak the
conoco phillips but the exxonmobil was
about almost a 4 billion dollar steak
one of his top 10 obviously oil having a
rough quarter and you know he dumped
there were some value investors like
seth klarman who actually boosted their
bow pose yeah bout post he boosted his
energy holdings pretty significantly but
as far as Warren Buffett goes energy was
the biggest reduction in his portfolio
mainly because of this excellent maybe
he's watching movies maybe he's watched
in 21st Century Fox movies right that's
that's a good point that's a good segue
that was one of his buys 21st Century
Fox and he also had a new buying
restaurant brands which is the
combination of Burger King and Tim
Hortons so some very buffett like
companies there for sure